everyone's like i want to grow my
instagram i'm like i'm aware selfish
[ __ ]
the amount of people that hit me up is
hundreds thousands of people who are sad
that they're not growing and then i will
go look at their account 90 of those
people don't even reply to the 15 people
that leave a comment you literally
posted something people literally
replied and you left it's like giving a
presentation people asking you questions
from the presentation and you're walking
out of the room and going home the only
way i got here to this moment from 2007
to 2011 i replied to every tweet that
was directed at me that's all i did for
a living 15 hours a day this is why i
get mad when you don't reply to the
eight people that do leave a comment
you're trying to get bigger and you
don't have time for the eight people
that actually care about you right now
i'm not from television i didn't have a
big platform i want it by building
actual community that's why i can pull
off econ it's actual community
and nobody does that